imagínate que quieres comprar una casa
pero antes de eso te gustaría saber cuál
es el área que ocupa es decir cuánta
superficie de terreno tienen los
cimientos de esa casa y para eso aquí
tienes el plano en este plano te dan
varias dimensiones te dan cuánto miden
algunas paredes por ejemplo este es de
18 pies 8 pies 20 25 26 pies 15 pies y
25 pies sin embargo hasta el momento
únicamente sabemos cómo encontrar el
área de rectángulos así que te invito a
que a partir de esta información
intentes encontrar el área de esta casa
utilizando únicamente las técnicas que
conocemos bueno como te comentaba la
única técnica que conocemos hasta
ahorita es como encontrar el área de un
rectángulo entonces a lo mejor convenga
dividir este plano en rectángulos más
pequeños por ejemplo aquí hay un
rectángulo aquí hay un rectángulo que va
de aquí para acá de aquí para acá y este
rectángulo lo conocemos bastante bien
sabemos cuál es su ancho
y cuál es su largo su ancho es 20 y su
largo es 20 de hecho es un cuadrado
aunque no parezca tenemos otros
rectángulos tenemos también uno por acá
déjame marcarlo en color azul sería más
o menos algo de este estilo ahora este
rectángulo no es tan evidente tan
evidente saber cuáles son sus
dimensiones sabemos que su ancho es 26
pero como le podemos hacer para
encontrar su largo
bueno pues observa que estos 5 pies con
este largo de aquí en total deben sumar
los 20 pies de esta otra pared entonces
el largo del rectángulo debe ser 15 15
pies otra vez 15 pies con estos cinco
pies suman los 20 pies de esta pared de
por acá vale que debe de ser igual a
esta de acá porque este es un rectángulo
bueno además de estos dos rectángulos
tenemos un rectángulo más grandote aquí
en medio
deja como la herramienta de rectángulo
sería algo más o menos así sale ahora lo
que tenemos en este rectángulo es el
largo pero no tenemos el ancho y como le
podemos hacer para calcular el ancho
bueno pues ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
a estos ocho pies sumarle esto de aquí
este ancho que es 20 y este de acá que
es 26 vale 26 más 8 34 20 50
por lo tanto el ancho de este rectángulo
es 54 pies y finalmente nos queda aquí
un rectángulo un poco más pequeño que
voy a pintar en color verde este de acá
y en este ya conocemos sus dimensiones
tiene ancho 25 y tiene el largo 15
entonces ahora sí podemos calcular el
área
simplemente encontramos el área de cada
uno de estos rectángulos y sumamos todo
déjame empezar con esta área de acá lo
voy a hacer en el mismo orden que los
dibuje entonces vamos a empezar con esta
área de acá
esta área que estoy marcando en rosa es
de 20 pies por 20 pies entonces sería 20
2020 a eso tenemos que sumar déjame
ponerlo en color blanco
tenemos que sumar el área azul esta área
de acá esta área de acá y el área de ese
rectángulo sería sería ancho por largo
26 x 15 + 26 x 15 no voy a poner las
unidades porque sería muy latosos vale
al final le ponemos pies cuadrados luego
déjame pasar a este de acá al área de
este rectángulo naranja
que sería sumar sería sumar 54 por 18
más 54 por 18 18 y finalmente tenemos
que sumar zinc ya no puse los signos más
en blanco bueno no importa finalmente
tenemos que sumar el área de este
rectángulo verde de acá que sería 25 por
15 más 25 por 15
bueno pues tenemos que hacer varias
cuentas 20 por 20 es igual a 400 lo
pongo aquí abajo 400 a eso tenemos que
sumar 26 por 15 voy a hacer la
multiplicación de este lado 26 por 15 a
ver cinco por seis es 30 llevamos 35 por
12 10 y 3 que llevamos 13
luego aquí va un 0 1 por 6 3 6 1 por 12
2 sumamos 0 y 0 0 3 609 unidos es 3
entonces 26 por 15 390 hay que sumar 390
luego vamos con el color naranja más 54
por 18 vamos a hacer la multiplicación
aquí 54 por 18
4.8 por 432 llevamos 38 por 5 es 43 que
llevamos 43 1 por 4 es 4 aquí hay que
poner un 0 1 por 4 es 4 1 por 5 5
sumamos 20 es 23 y 4 de 7 459 entonces
aquí es 972 muy bien y finalmente
tenemos que sumar 25 por 15 creo que no
tenemos que hacerla porque ya tenemos 26
por 15 que es 390 así que simplemente a
390 hay que restarle 15 390 menos 15 es
375 entonces tenemos que sumar 300 375 y
ahora simplemente hay que sumar todo
esto de aquí entonces vamos a hacer la
suma sería 400 más 390
mas 972
+ 375 375 ya casi terminamos de hecho
aquí merecemos un redoble de tambores
para hacer la suma la voy a poner en
color amarillo 12 57 25 es 7 9 y 7 16 y
7 es 23 3 y llevamos 22 y 46 6 y 39 y 9
18 y 3 es 21 21 2.137 entonces el área
de esta casa sería de 2 mil 137 pies
pies cuadrados cuadras
vale entonces esta técnica de dividir
una figura extraña en rectángulos puede
resultarte de utilidad a lo mejor no
sabes cómo encontrar el área de la
figura extraña a simple vista pero
puedes reducir el problema a problemas
más pequeños